mark just got tell you there's no room
on the lectern
I'm Bonnie Jansen I'm with the Federal
Trade Commission we've been working very
closely with the North American
securities administrators Association on
project field of schemes today you will
have three main speakers they're listed
in your press packet each of them will
have a set of remarks we will be showing
a video news release we also will be
identifying other people who are helpful
or have actually participated in project
field of schemes all of them also will
be available for your questions at the
end of the prepared remarks then we will
invite reporters to go over afterward
and view and demonstration of an
interactive investment quiz that the
Federal Trade Commission has developed
and that's available on our website
these materials up here are brochures
that have been given by these various
firms that we've targeted to consumers
they will remain up here for you to film
after the close of the formal press
event in addition all of our speakers
and those who are being acknowledged
also will remain up here for you to
direct additional interviews with after
the close of the formal press event we
would ask that we have questions from
working press only and if you could
please identify yourself in your
affiliation when you ask your question
so that we know who we're speaking with
I would also note that we have
additional materials that are going to
be placed on the press table at the
close of the event please do stop by and
pick up those materials as you leave
today we are available throughout the
rest of the day to handle your follow-up
questions contact numbers on the last
page of the news release in your press
packet now I'd like to introduce mark
griffin president of NASA
good afternoon I'm mark griffin
president of the North American
securities administrators Association
also known as NASA NASA was founded 78
years ago in 1919 and n the u.s. is the
collective voice of the 50 states
securities agencies and we also
represent the 13 Canadian securities
agencies as well we are in charge of
protecting the small investor today we
are announcing that securities agencies
from 20 21 states to Canadian provinces
and the Federal Trade Commission have
taken 61 law enforcement actions as part
of project field of schemes some of
these actions are for registration
violations but at their core we believe
that many of these schemes are intended
to mislead and defraud investors six
months in the making this law
enforcement campaign was designed to mow
down the expanding field of investment
fraud that is outpacing the combined
amount of different of money defrauded
from consumers in all other kinds of
telemarketing scams coordinated jointly
by NASA and the FTC field of schemes and
compasses a contemptible array of
investment scams most were offered to
potential investors through unsolicited
telephone cold calling these schemes run
the gamut from worthless oil and gas
programs in Kentucky and digital
fingerprint identification technology in
Indiana to non-existent internet sites
in California and multi-level marketing
schemes in Quebec Canada they include
ostrich ranching in Idaho retirement
investments for the clergy in Maryland
and interest in frozen embryos from
Macau in Ohio named misty cool the Iowa
Securities Bureau informs us that it's
taken action against an entity known as
us snail that sold a business
opportunity that involved breeding
snails for snail ranching according to
the company sales literature hella
culture or snail ranching has become one
of the newest and fast
growing business fields in the United
States scam artists that play upon the
unwary never fail to pull out all the
emotional stops as well to keep to get
people to part with their hard-earned
money the Pennsylvania Securities
Commission for example has taken action
against an investment company that sold
what they call commercial promissory
notes for twenty five thousand dollars
apiece to supposedly construct
state-of-the-art medical facilities in
Hungary a water treatment facility in
Zaire and roadways and infrastructures
in war-torn Bosnia if there's one thing
that project fields of schemes
demonstrates its that swindlers are
becoming more creative in how they
obtain people's money and with the
rising bull market in legitimate stocks
providing double-digit returns too many
people are willing to believe the
unbelievable when it comes to the kind
of scams that we are talking about today
indeed losses from these non-traditional
investment schemes are outpacing the
combined amount from defrauded from
investors in all other kinds of
telemarketing scams in each state and
province there is a local securities
agency to which you may go to for help
when these schemes are pounding on your
door and calling you on the telephone
call us we're the local cop on the beat
and we'd like to hear from you there are
those that believe that if you build a
scheme they will come well I need to
inform them that if they do build it we
will come and shut it down and we're
appropriate we will make criminal
referrals to criminal prosecutor 'i'll
agencies I need to tell you now that
will show you a video news release that
will go by satellite broadcast this
afternoon and our technical people can
help us out on that and you can train
your attention to the TV set
this was the scene after an alleged
telemarketing boiler room was rated as
part of a surprise crackdown by law
enforcement officials authorized by
state security officials from more than
20 states to Canadian provinces and the
US Federal Trade Commission the schemes
entice investors with visions of gold
mines Hollywood movie profits and
high-tech riches the con artists tool to
gain entry into the victims bank account
is the telephone returns that are just
in the astronomical so when those are
becoming much more creative and how
they're stealing other people's money
and unfortunately the rise in today's
bull markets make investors believe the
unbelievable and these types of
non-traditional investment schemes are
starting to far outpace what we're
seeing in the telemarketing frogs nice
to fraud information 7 may I help you
the washington-based National Fraud
information center reports that
investment fraud is on the rise it's
hotline has received record calls
pertaining to investment related scams
this year the only ones who profit in
this field of schemes are the scam
artists themselves their tactics are
powerful and unfortunately for consumers
quite effective they promise high
profits and low risks and their maker
claims believable by pointing to
successful track records guaranteed
income and major corporations waiting to
buy these investments they package their
claims and glossy brochures and they use
high-pressure sales tactics to tell
consumers they have to act quickly in
the FTC's cases alone consumers may have
spent 150 million dollars in such
schemes we saved the Commission if they
build a scheme they will come I invested
six thousand dollars and was promised
six thousand back within the year
% interest plus 600 in the stocks and I
invested like my entire life savings
thought I was going to get it back
within a year was going to put it
towards a new home and now I have
nothing with investment scams sprouting
like weeds nASA released today an
investor alert entitled project field of
schemes which contains valuable
information about investment fraud NASA
and the FTC advise investors to be wary
of non-traditional investments with no
risk claims promises of big profits in a
short period of time high-pressure get
rich quick deals suspicious testimonials
from other investors for a free copy of
the investor alert right to field of
schemes in asaa one massachusetts avenue
northwest suite 310 washington DC 2000
one in Washington this is lee sheppard
reporting as you can see this is a very
serious problem our advice to the
investing public when they receive these
types of calls is to keep one hand on
your wallet and hang up the phone thank
you now I would like to turn over the
podium to Theresa Schwartz of the
Federal Trade Commission the FTC has
been an invaluable Ally in the in the
fight against investment-related fraud I
want to express my gratitude especially
to Bob Freeman and Doug Gordimer and the
rest of your staff thank you
thank you Mark good afternoon I am
pleased to share the platform with NASA
to announce field of schemes a project
targeting telemarketing investment fraud
and pyramid schemes these frauds have
become epidemic they are increasing in
number and type everything from new
schemes involving internet shopping
malls and movie productions to age-old
schemes that involve oil drilling
ventures gemstones and pyramids all
these schemes are like in one very
important way the only ones to profit
are the scam artists in fact consumer
losses are enormous in the 9 FTC cases
announced today consumers may have paid
defendants 150 million dollars in our
complaint database investment frauds now
account for more dollar injury to
consumers than any other category of
telemarketing fraud fraudulent
investment promoters use similar tactics
they follow the headlines to find
ventures that are likely to be
marketable to consumers so hot new
technologies like the Internet are
especially fertile ground for fraud they
project tremendously high profits and
low risks and they make completely false
claims about their track records they
package their claims and slick
promotional materials that give the
illusion of legitimacy they are masters
of the high-pressure sales pitch this
venture they tell consumers is the truly
unique opportunity that must be seized
quickly or forever be lost
these tactics and more were used in the
schemes targeted by the FTC one case
involving new technology ventures was a
massive sophisticated and unfortunately
for consumers highly successful scheme
unfortunately many of the scammed
consumers were elderly the entire scheme
involved a nationwide network of
telemarketing boiler rooms and cost
consumers approximately 30 million
dollars among the offerings in this
scheme were partnerships in virtual
shopping malls touted as the next
version of televisions QVC Shopping
Network only better because the internet
promises a global marketplace this
partnership was structured to give the
promoters eighty-five percent of the
proceeds only fifteen percent went into
operations thus making it a sure fail
rather than a surefire venture the
promised businesses in this scheme never
materialized and contrary to the
promised returns investors were left
with little or nothing of their
hard-earned money perhaps the saddest
thing and this story is that a number of
the investors invested more than once
they were reseted or reloaded to invest
again before they knew their first
investment had failed another tactic
scam artists use is to make false claims
that third parties are interested in
their investment or have confirmed its
value for instance promoters in another
of the FTC's cases told prospective
investors in their gold mine and silver
mine that two major corporations Exxon
and Mitsubishi had expressed strong
interest in acquiring one of the minds
they also claimed that the US government
studies had confirmed the presence of
millions of dollars worth of mineral
deposits
in the line in the mines the truth
neither corporation had ever expressed
any interest in either of the minds and
the government study actually contained
no data on which or reserves could be
calculated the defendants reloaded
investors in this scheme too they
quickly paid out seven point five
percent return on though for those who
invest it in the first mine and then
recruited them to buy into the second
line and seventy-five percent of them
did up against such fraudulent schemes
and unscrupulous operators consumers
must learn to protect themselves indeed
we view consumer education as the first
line of defense against fraud and it is
an important part of our field of
schemes initiatives to get the message
out about investment fraud we have
developed materials that are in the
press packet and included in our
materials for the first time an
interactive game which we are showing
you later that is linked to the FTC's
web page and the tests consumers IQ in
this case in investment quotient our
advice to consumers contained in these
materials might be boiled down to the
following before you invest always get a
second opinion that is seek out the
advice of a financial professional don't
let yourself be pressured research the
company and the offering and finally be
skeptical of unsolicited phone calls
about investments and hang up on those
that downplay risk and talk about
enormous profits had consumers sought a
second opinion about the virtual mole
partnership they would have learned that
the enterprise was structured to fail
had those solicited to invest in the
mining operation made a call to Exxon or
Mitsubishi they would have learned that
the promoters were lying
as law enforcement agencies chase the
scam artists they move on to new fields
these tips can help consumers stay a
step ahead as was mentioned earlier many
agencies have contributed to the success
of the field of schemes project and I
would like to acknowledge a few
individuals who have joined us today and
who also will be happy to answer your
questions later from the Securities and
Exchange Commission Colleen Mahoney jus
Stan Colleen deputy director division of
enforcement from the Commodity Futures
Trading Commission Larry Norton is here
assistant director of the enforcement
division from the Council of Better
Business Bureaus we have Stephen Jones
who is director of policy and standards
and from our education partner in this
enterprise the Alliance for investor
education Michael Jones thank you now I
would like to introduce David kid
attorney for an Akron Ohio couple who
invested in the internet related
partnership scheme which I mentioned
earlier in my remarks and which is also
described in more detail in your press
packet mr. kid
thank you very much normally I would say
I'm happy to be here but actually I'm
really sorry to have to be here today
I'm not an attorney I have some friends
who came to me daughters of an elderly
couple who approached me as a private
citizen and a friend too I helped them
with an investment that their father had
gotten into to see if we could figure
out what he had done and how to maybe
get his money back my degrees in finance
and I have some background in some
security related matters and so I tried
to help them with that turns out that
the couple was not actually in Akron
Ohio but near there an elderly couple
named Paul and Eloise wood were
approached in December of 1995 by
telephone to invest in a general
partnership that was california-based to
participate in the rapid growth and
profits available in the expanding
internet they really don't understand
the internet but the prospect of profits
evidently appealed to Paul and Eloise
frankly has had no idea what her husband
has been doing all these years for
investing Paul was 85 years old his wife
is 79 Paul is all but def and if you
shout on the phone he can get about half
of what you say but he does read and
speak well his wife is legally blind and
across the room can know somebody's
there but not know who they are until
they speak so as a couple of this as an
investor this couple had a net worth of
under $100,000 most of which is their
home and property they had only about
forty thousand dollars in liquid assets
of cash in savings and checking and they
were convinced to invest ten thousand
dollars into one of the internet
projects it's listed today for I guess
pending charges for fraud the
the telephone solicitors were very
cordial and convincing and Paul felt
like it was a really great opportunity
and he he thought the return sounded
great and they may have represented some
things on the phone that we're not in
the offering memorandum but if you look
at the offer room offering themselves
there were a number of partnerships that
were put out by this group these are the
glossy covers of the prospectus or
offering memorandums for two of those
partnerships future net and home net
shopping which also are on the table the
the contents of these brochures are
appalling frankly the the solicitors
have done a good job of disclosing that
they were going to take most of the
money quite upfront and basically rely
on the fact that they're dealing with
very unsophisticated investors who don't
understand what that means in terms of
their investment in this case Paul has
probably no ability to understand the
you know the implications of the
partnership it even says right at the in
the fine print where you sign that that
they may you know use as much as eighty
five percent of the money in fees I'm
sure he wasn't able to read that fine
print in any case in fact in this
particular instance he said he couldn't
fill out the forms and this the
solicitors in this particular project as
evidence in the depositions that we made
we're happy to fill those out for him if
he would just sign the bottom line and
mail it to them along with a cashier's
check and for some people when they get
a FedEx package with information like
this in it and signed the form and go to
the bank and get a check it's kind of
exciting for them and they really feel
like they're doing something important
in his case he was also he questioned
the legitimacy this whole thing and was
told that it was quote approved by the
government so whatever that meant it
helped him to feel more confident a few
months later he was approached again
after a couple letters saying
everything's going great and in told it
looks like they're going to make a lot
of money and what
put another five thousand dollars up and
he did so he put he thought he was in
the same partnership but he ended up
being in a different partnership and
again as an outsider going in to try to
figure this out it took me about five
visits in about 20 hours to find all the
paperwork to figure out what he had done
the with the daughters we filled a
complaint out with the Ohio and
California divisions of security we had
written the company and had Paul sign a
letter to send certified to try to ask
him to return his money it was never
picked up at the post office we are very
grateful for the fact that in a very
short period of time by my experience
the Federal Trade Commission picked up
on this and was able to take some action
and now are you know attempting to
secure whatever remaining assets may be
available to try to return them to these
investors I would like to commend the
Federal Trade Commission on that action
and in-state that I've never seen a
government agency act so fast on things
like this I would say as a private
citizen that I'm appalled that this kind
of thing is continuing and as someone
who's at the tail end of the baby boomer
age it appears to me that work we have
people at the beginning of the baby
boomer period approaching retirement and
you know getting to the point where they
may need help with their investments
what's going to happen over the next 20
years as the rest of us go through that
process I think the market for these
kind of scams is going to grow actually
and the potential for fraud is going to
grow and this kind of action of you know
getting on these schemes and trying to
stop them is going to become
increasingly important from this family
standpoint I would say that the family
didn't know what the father had done if
there's any wives or husbands out there
who don't know what their spouse is
doing with their investments that's the
red flag right there and people need to
insist that they sit down and if they
don't participate in decision making at
least know what's going on or family
members need to get involved in this
case Paul really didn't trust anyone in
his family immediate members to advise
him on his things and or to help him to
monitor his investments and it took an
outsider to come in and help in that
regard and I was happy to play that role
in this particular family there's a
cliche in the industry that if it sounds
too good to be true it it is and I would
hope that the media can help to promote
these kind of things and not only to
educate the community to watch out for
these kind of investments but also to
encourage in some way the families to
get more involved with their parents as
they as they reached these ages there's
some other incidentals about the project
I'm happy to answer afterwards on what
he got involved in and if anyone really
we've had Paul changes phone number it's
unlisted but if anyone has the urge to
speak with this couple directly it may
be that we can arrange for them to call
you at your office and talk to you and
get a little interview if if necessary
but it wouldn't have been appropriate to
have them come in today for for health
reasons thank you very much
and I at this point we'd like to go
ahead and take your questions please
join me risa right here right here
beside yes to thing I'm interested in
what you all have found a thing to the
target audience for the for these scam
artists and how they select their
targets what sort of a victim they're
looking for and the second thing I'm
curious about is what sort of rate of
return you all managed to come up with
when somebody complains and you step in
how much of what people have put into
these fraudulent things do they ever get
back if any well I can I can take a stab
at an answer to that the common profile
of a victim in these types of schemes is
a person who cannot hang up the phone
that's the one commonality I they tend
to be fairly polite they don't want to
be rude if I had to make a pic on
demographics i would say elderly are
tend to be victims of these frauds
particularly because they're targeted
the elderly have saved a nest egg they
have discretionary funds they tend to be
polite they tend to have some time to
talk and so they are they are targeted
by very sophisticated cold calling
operations that have cold calling lists
that identify these people and the the
other question is what money can you
expect to get back our experience among
the states is that it's difficult to get
this money back because so much of it
goes offshore after its initially
invested it tiptoes to the location
where it lands and then quickly goes
into countries where they were bank
secrecy laws and other things and I'd
like to recent answer from the FTC's
point people well the range of victims
can be enormous the scam artists are
playing on concerns about financial
security so you get the elderly consumer
worried about retirement
you also get younger families worried
about educating their kids and you get
middle middle aged folks who are worried
about corporate downsizing so it's a
broad abroad span they're certainly our
targets we haven't discovered many
sucker lists which are oftentimes lists
of elderly people that are visited and
revisited and reloaded and risa listed
which we've we've heard about today the
amount of money that we are able to
recover varies tremendously depending on
whether the assets have been moved ahead
of us but we do have authority to seek
temporary restraining orders and asset
freezes and we we do have success when
we can locate resources which we do in
freezing those assets and returning them
to consumers yes Marcy Gordon with the
AP could you give us a break down please
in terms of dollar amounts between the
more conventional frauds and these
up-and-coming few schemes and to try to
show us as you said that one is starting
to outpace the other would you like to
feel no I'd say it's a that's a
difficult question to answer only when
you think of more conventional frauds
obviously within the domain of the
Securities and Exchange Commission nila
stock market frauds and so forth you're
speaking about very large numbers I
think the focus of this project is you
might say on the more sort of non non
traditional fraud tell marketing frauds
a lot of pyramid scams one thing we can
say is that telemarketing fraud in
general is thought to cause consumers
injury of up to perhaps forty billion
dollars a year it's thought and what
we're seeing now is it seems a real
trend towards more and more
telemarketers turning away from certain
types of more black and white frauds
into the investment fraud area it's more
lucrative it's I think there may be a
sense in some of the telemarketers that
maybe they might have a give criminal
a little harder time if they do this so
we're certainly talking about hundreds
and millions of dollars of harm in this
type of area the precise answers it's
just a cold come by if I can follow up
on that question the the statement I
think that you gave me Schwartz was that
investment frauds account for more
dollar injury to consumers than any
other area of telemarketing fraud what
other kinds of telemarketing fraud are
there other than investment I thought
that was telling my what's what
telemarketing was was trying to get
people to invest in something well
there's a there I'm again a broad range
but we've been involved recently with
business opportunities which are pitched
by the telephone travel scams are
pitched over the telephone lauder
lotteries or sweepstakes so there's a
almost an unending list as broad as your
imagination of what to has pitched over
the telephone and we are pursuing a
number of these and have been throughout
the year but in some ways aren't some of
these sort of old old perennial
favorites like offers to invest in a
gold mine they seem old and you have to
ask yourself how could someone fall for
this but then you see the materials
which Mr Kydd presented and they they
look very sophisticated and you get a
government report that seems to confirm
the value of the assets in the in the
case of the gold mine there the mine was
located on patented claims which were US
government patented claims the problem
was the patent claim means nothing about
the or or resources on the property
because in this case they were issued
before 1900 so you wrap what appears to
be an incredible scheme with the
legitimate looking sounding documents
and very skilled pitch artists and it
became becomes more credible and
seemingly more legitimate yeah piggyback
I'm sure that different kinds of
telemarketing fraud particularly with
the Better Business Bureau experience
there's there's been four years many
kinds of frauds particularly people
offering prizes for money
offering land offering trips vacations
then this is runnin millions and
millions of dollars as well and
continues to this day it may be if not
dwarfed by the investment fraud because
of the amounts are so much larger but
there are hundreds of thousands of
people who are daily approached by
people telling them but they've that
they've won a prize and all they have to
do is pay the taxes on it a five hundred
dollars now have a new Ford deliver to
their house something like that they're
from the state's point of view also
these types of scams are probably the
second oldest profession that makes them
of more concern to us because now we
have information technology the
scamsters have made their pitches highly
evolved and they are as you see by the
evidence presented today affecting
Americans Canadians in in ways that are
devastating to our elderly population
can be devastating to our younger
population as well so the fact that they
are still going around ought to be of
more concern to us because they do get
much more sophisticated yes can you tell
us what what some of these 61 law
enforcement actions are in our and those
nine cases are you filing them today
announcing them what's well I can speak
on behalf of the states we are we are
announcing that they have been recently
filed the the cases are documented in
the press materials they have brief
summaries of what the cases are about
they they vary in everything from soup
to nuts they they cover the range of
possible whatever the human mind can
conceive can be sold as an investment
it's been our experience so I don't know
about the FTC cases that have been
recently filed I'll let them answer okay
I'm told I should introduce myself Dean
greyville for the FTC with respect to
the FTC cases these are filed in federal
court they there are nine cases eight of
which I can speak about one at one is
under seal they were filed within the
last several weeks and one thing that we
try to do in our fraud cases is go in
with
or a preliminary relief which would in
many cases seek to freeze the assets
that we may find they're heavy what we
call a receiver appointed by the court
to actually run the business in a lawful
manner while while matters are sorted
out and also prohibitions on the conduct
which is the blatant misrepresentations
so in our cases at least you know we're
we're in that sort of legal wrangling
stage of having filed those motions
receivers are in place and then you know
that the defense makes their case as
well sorry find these civil cases
request they are there any criminal
cases that can filed as a result of this
how much of the state's moved to recover
it's difficult to quantify the amount
that the states have have to move to
recover it's frankly difficult to
coordinate all of this and these these
investigations are in process these are
cases that have been filed we expect to
recover substantial amounts of money but
as I have said our experience is that we
can't recover all the money and it's
very dangerous to invest in these
because the money usually goes offshore
or through several bank accounts and
it's difficult to trace I think it's
safe to say that there will probably be
criminal referrals out of this pool of
cases
and actually one follow-up to that is
that in a number of cases the FBI has in
the course of their own independent
investigations have served search
warrants on a number of the targets that
we are also pursuing yes two-part
question about investment fraud on the
Internet of the 150 billion million
dollar figure that was mentioned can you
quantify what portion of that is
basically internet-related investment
fraud scams and specifically in terms of
the FTC if this is proliferating to the
degree that you are saying that it is
does it make the case for more FTC or
government regulation of Internet
commerce sooner rather than later I'll
let the FTC answer that question another
agency here that I that that has some
expertise in that is the SEC colima
holding you you might want to come up
and speak for a minute on their behalf
and i'll let the FTC why don't you
answer the question first okay the with
respect to the 150 million dollar figure
one of those pyramid schemes the jewel
way case which has both an internet and
other marketing component is we believe
a very large number the company itself
claimed to have taken in over a hundred
million dollars in one year the other
Internet related investments again this
is a request to invest in like the
internet shopping mall idea or Internet
service provider idea that one case
brought in LA we believe was at least 30
million dollars so it's a pretty large
component in regard to the question of
what the FTC should do I would simply
say that you know this is an instance
where in a way you have traditional law
enforcement in a different medium
companies going to go by the telephone
they can go by the internet and our
approach is
simply to try to be as aggressive as we
can whatever the medium in cyberspace I
mean isn't it time to get essence to get
a bigger and quicker posse well one one
approach I need to let you speak one one
one approach on the internet that the
FTC in particular is trying to pursue
because of how fluid you know things can
be in that medium is a lot of consumer
education trying to give warnings to
people trying to alert people that just
because it's on the internet it doesn't
mean that it's got any more legitimacy
that you can have a website that looks
as professional as as a legitimate
companies so aggressive law enforcement
partnering with the industry and
consumer education are really the way
we're going at the moment thank you I
guess in terms of the question of
resources and whether or not there is a
lot of fraud going on out there I mean
there's no question about it that you
know we are concerned about the level of
fraud that is going on in the market
that's always been a concern of ours and
I but I think with the message to be
here today I mean do we need more
resources we could always use more
resources but what consumers and
investors are getting out of the program
like the one you're seeing today is the
benefit of coordinated resources among
the government agencies to deal in a
sort of collective fashion to get the
maximum amount of our resources to deal
with fraud on the internet and in the
market as a whole in terms of whether we
need more regulation I think the answer
to that at this point is we're not
really asking for for more regulatory
authority the schemes that we're talking
about today our garden variety fraud
whether they're conducted over the
telephone over the Internet I mean the
conduct will follow the technology and
the technology will create opportunities
for people to meet or to deal with or to
reach out to as many investors as they
possibly can and I think that we have
been very proactive both as an agency
the SEC and working with other agencies
to make sure that people know that we
are out there we are surveilling the
internet we are bringing cases involving
scams that are perpetrated over the
Internet and that's something that we're
going to continue to do
going forward so more resources I think
as long as we are coordinated we can do
the best we can to maximize all the
resources that each of us have and in
terms of more regulation I think as long
as we have a general anti fraud statute
we can deal with a lot most of the
problems that we see out there the
Internet can you just go into that a
little bit well we have attorneys in the
enforcement division have our trained on
the internet and we have a group of
attorneys that are regularly dealing
with or surveilling the Internet to pick
up possible scams that might be out
there we also have opened an enforcement
complaint center that gives people an
opportunity to communicate with us about
scams that they might be seeing on the
internet or about investment problems in
general and at this point we're getting
between I think 30 to 40 complaints
every day on the internet or through our
enforcement complaint center that we're
following up on and using as a basis for
bringing enforcement actions and like
the FTC we like to bring these cases as
quickly as possible so that we can
secure along with the state's any
investor assets that might be available
to get money back to people who have
been hurt the the resource that we
really need in the fight against
investment fraud on the internet and
against investment fraud in general is
an educated public the first line of
defense is the person who is answering
the the one adds the Internet I don't
think that we can expect the Internet to
be policed we can pull things off we can
investigate scams we can run sting
operations but in in one sense yes the
the regulators are outgunned in fighting
investment fraud on the internet but on
the telephone as well and so consumers
need to know some some basic things
about investing that will protect them
and and I agree with all that but may I
just say just from a slightly different
perspective that the Internet is a tool
for the scam artist it's also a tool for
us in law enforcement and we are putting
it to use recently the Federal Trade
Commission has done some surf days in a
13 hour period all across the country
our partners in law enforcement surfed
the web and for pyramid schemes
came up with 500 pyramid schemes we
immediately sent e-mails back to these
operators and checked later and almost
twenty percent had shut down and we're
looking at the rest of them we've done
this again with business opportunities
so it is a tool and we're putting it to
good use and I think will increase
increasingly dough so yeah I just had
one more thing from the perspective of
the self regulation which is a better
business degree of you and I guess I'm
taking these opportunities sort of thump
our own chest but we have begun our own
program called ve be online in which
which companies can have a bug on their
internet site that you click to find out
about them they have to in order to have
that bug they have to be checked out and
visited personally by investigators for
the Better Business Bureau and that's a
certain amount of surance that'll give
that you're not doing business with
someone who is fly-by-night and that's a
program that's just that's begun
recently and his end is up and up and
running now internet of someone who
ingests on the internet internet scheme
isn't a unsophisticated elderly blind
person got a new hood who's who is
paying off all this money you have a
profile of computer our experience has
been that on the internet of course we
are talking demographics a younger
generation somewhat but there's another
commonality too and that is the peoples
peoples need to invest and their fancy
for greed I think has something to do
with it we all want large returns we all
want to believe that that we can make
money as others have in the markets and
these types of investments are pitched
in very glossy formats as you've seen
today and on the internet it's equally
as effective people do want to believe
that they can make these types of
returns and what we're suggesting is is
that they exercise a great degree of
caution that they check out with their
state securities regulators and with
federal authorities where they're not
have been any complaints filed people
who are selling securities or
investments have to be licensed in all
the jurisdictions in which they're
operating so a quick call to your state
securities agency will check
on that license if the person is not
licensed if the investments not licensed
that's a red flag right there they're
not complying with the law one last
question and former part terrorists with
the night business but I just want to
clarify and it has one other question
which is what in the cases that you
filed here though these do not involve
people most of them do not involve
people being solicited via the internet
these are people got calls and were
pressured by calls to invest I just want
make sure that was correct although the
investment touted something to do with
the internet and the second question I
want to ask I think it was maybe last
year you were all here talking about or
the same organizations were here talking
about precisely the same thing internet
scams we're growing and people were
losing a lot of money by them and I've
covered these stories and I think
everybody here has for a number of years
I'm wondering what we can say now that
would be different than we've said over
past years which might affect any of
these people to behave differently
Teresa went well one reason we called
you all here today was that we hoped you
would write about this and that we would
get out the message we're trying new
ways with the internet interactive game
which is something new to to reach
consumers make it fun and interesting
and educational the education rule that
we're playing is served not only by
these materials but also by bringing the
law enforcement actions and holding
press conferences and bringing it home
to consumers what a big problem that it
is and and we're also trying to send a
message to the scam artists that were on
the beat and that we're following them
and pursuing them in a cohesive way so
we stay at it I think one of the
messages is that as we engage in law
enforcement in one area the scam artist
moved to others and then we move there
too but it is a reoccurring theme I
would agree with you on that on that
score and we're just staying with it um
mr. kid if he might would like to make a
brief
closing remark just to piggyback on that
comment the in the case of the wood
family we have a very close-knit loving
family with three daughters in the Sun
and they had no idea what their father
had been investing in and we're quite
shocked to discover that he had not only
made this particular investment but we
found a long history of not so great
investments in all of these kind of
things lots of money lost in futures and
options and an a history of money lost
in all these sweepstake things it's it's
obvious that he's on the sucker list or
the mooch list and and and the family
had no idea so I you know if you wonder
who the victims are in this thing and
who the investors are it may be your
parents and so you need to talk to your
parents and in the reason I'm here and
the reason I agreed to come wasn't so
much to help them do their legislative
and legal thing you know governmental
thing but to help ask you the media to
ask families to talk to each other
because the regulatory officials can
only get involved after there's a
problem they can look for and try to
prevent some of them but the only way we
can do the best prevention is to get the
families to talk to each other and keep
these things from coming up the first
place mr. Griffith get used answer the
first part of his question are most of
these internet scams initiated over the
phone
not necessarily no I think it's
difficult to quantify in that in those
terms the Internet in very reduced terms
is like a huge classified ad system that
goes global it's a solicitation for
money whether or not you're buying
commodities products or investments in
this instance it's a new technology I'm
sure that most of you recognize that
five years ago this this wasn't a story
this technology is advancing rapidly and
it's it's challenging us I think we're
up to the challenge but we need some
assistance from consumers who are using
the internet to realize one that there
are scams on the internet and to no one
police's those channels no one looks at
what goes on the internet before it's
put there and three as soon as it's put
there it can come off tomorrow and it
provides relative anonymity to those who
use it and tomorrow your investment may
be gone so those are three cautionary a
pieces of advice that we would have for
consumers who are using the internet and
with that I think